Ulrike Herrmann ist Autorin und
wirtschaftskorrespondentin bei der taz
und der Landsberg ist
Hauptgeschäftsführer des Städte und
Gemeindebundes
Heilmann haben Sie denn die Ehre des
Bundestages gerettet
das ist glaube ich ein bisschen viel ich
hoffe dass ich dazu beigetragen kann
dass wir zukünftig bessere
Verfahren haben die sich ein wenig also
wir reden über zwei drei Wochen wenig
mehr Zeit nehmen
und wir deswegen weniger Fehler ins
Gesetzgebungsverfahren kriegen denn
darunter leiden die Gesetze schon lange
und in dieser Legislaturperiode
besonders
wenn man das jetzt liest die Begründung
aus Karlsruhe dann ist der Vorwurf
wahrscheinlich nicht weit hergeholt dass
das Klimaschutz mit der Brechstange war
die Ampel sehr offensichtlich auch ein
weiteres Mal beschädigt was das wird
also wichtig ist ja dass es um das
Verfahren geht sondern und nicht um den
Inhalt des Gesetzes und da muss man das
ja auch einordnen Heimat kann es als
Jurist wahrscheinlich noch besser ein
und als ich es ist ja noch nicht
entschieden worden dass diese Prozess
wir in den Bundestag hatten falsch war
sondern es ist von Karlsruhe eben Stadt
gegeben worden dass Ihr Anliegen nicht
und begründet ist und das ist normal
geprüft wird ausführlich
aber natürlich ist es für uns der Punkt
wo wir sagen aus Respekt vor diesem
laufenden Verfahren und vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht werden wir das
Gebäude Energiegesetz in dieser Woche
nicht verabschieden sondern werden das
entsprechend nach der Sommerpause im
Bundestag aufsetzen das ist die
Konsequenz die wir daraus ziehen wir
hatten gedacht dass unser Verfahren
passt und also wir haben zwei Anhörungen
gemacht ein ganz normales Verfahren in
diesem Sinne 15 Juni was das erste Mal
aufgesetzt diese Woche soll das
verabschiedet werden das war eine nicht
Sitzungswoche dazwischen aber wir müssen
eben jetzt sehen dass das Ansehen von
Herrn Heilmann nicht von vornherein als
unbegründet zurückgewiesen wurde vom
bundesverfassungsverfassungsgericht und
dass wir das insofern nicht jetzt so
durchführen werden wie geplant weil das
Gesetz ja eigentlich in der jetzigen
Form erst letzten Freitag eingereicht
worden ist es gab vorher so leicht
Planken das würde ja auch nicht als
Frist akzeptiert Landsberg das scheint
ja eine erhoffte ver auf Pause für die
Kommunen zu sein was bringt ihnen das
jetzt diese Verschiebung mutmaßlich auf
die erste Sitzungswoche Anfang September
und ja zunächst mal ist das ein klares
Signal dass die Verfahren so wie sie
gelaufen sind jedenfalls nicht die
Akzeptanz des Verfassungsgerichts
gefunden haben es bringt uns dann was
wenn die Ampel bereit ist noch mal
wirklich Beratung zuzulassen ich will
ein Beispiel nennen wir haben an einem
Freitag 92 Seiten Formulierungshilfe
bekommen und sollten am Montag eine
Stellungnahme zu einem Gesetz abgeben
was tief in die Rechte der Kommunen der
Bürger des Eigentums eingreift und wenn
man ehrlich ist realistisch gut konnten
wir das nicht machen wir müssen das ja
auch koppeln mit unseren Mitgliedern da
hat man schon ein bisschen den Eindruck
gehabt eigentlich was völlig egal was
wir sagen die wollten das durchziehen
und insofern habe ich das in gewisser
Weise begrüßt weil man es sollte ja der
große Aufschlag für den Klimaschutz
werden dieses Gesetz jetzt nur noch
Katzenjammer
also ich glaube dass die Wärmepumpe
kommen wird einfach aus dem ganz simplen
Grund dass wir einen Klimaschutzgesetz
haben übrigens verabschiedet unter der
Regierung Merkel nicht also die CDU tut
ja jetzt so als hätte sie noch nie von
Klimaschutz gehört ich nehme meinen
Herrn ein Mann aus aber wir müssen bis
2045 klimaneutral sein und das
funktioniert nur wenn die
Einfamilienhäuser und das sind immerhin
16 von fast 20 Millionen Häusern also
fast alle Wohngebäude sind ein
Familienhäuser und Klimaneutralität
funktioniert nur wenn diese
Einfamilienhäuser Wärmepumpen einbauen
und das ist jetzt auch keine also man
hat ja hier das Gefühl wenn man in
Deutschland zuguckt bei der Diskussion
als wäre das eine völlig neue
Technologie die sensationell schwierig
ist ja aber alle Nachbarstaaten die
Schweiz der in den Markt Schweden
Norwegen die bauen schon alle die
Wärmepumpe ein auch weil die Bürger ja
verstehen dass das die bessere
Alternative ist und deswegen würde ich
mal denken auch in Deutschland kommt die
Wasserpumpe ein Mann sie waren ja
eigentlich relativ allein auf weiter
Flur mit dieser Klage ihre Fraktion hat
das glaube ich nach bei einer
Pressekonferenz fahren was sie im
Schilde führen hatten sie jetzt
schmücken sich natürlich alle mit diesem
Erfolg aus Karlsruhe in Heften sich das
andere Wehr ein voran ihr
Fraktionsvorsitzender
haben sie da das Gefühl gehabt dass das
immer unterstützt wird oder war das so
sagen jetzt ich muss jetzt gehen muss
voran weil sonst passiert nichts
also die Idee
aus einem individuellen
abgeordnetenrecht ist ja kein Recht der
Fraktion sondern ein einzelrecht zu
klagen die kommt von mir das ist auch
nicht zufällig so weil ich mit dem Thema
Klima und Energie ja intensiv befasst
bin und ich bin seit vielen Jahren auch
schon der letzten Legislaturperiode eine
Staatsmodernisierung erarbeite und
Kämpfe und da auch Berichterstatter bin
in einer Fraktion und mich deswegen mit
den Gesetzgebungsverfahren sehr intensiv
auseinandergesetzt habe wir haben uns
dann entschlossen mit Wissen und Wollen
von Thorsten frei der das koordiniert
hat dass unser erster PDF aber natürlich
wusste das auf Friedrich Merz und dann
hat die Fraktion sich bewusst
entschieden dass ich alleine Klage
juristisch aber die Fraktion hat ein
zehnseitiges schreiben beim
Verfassungsgericht eingereicht dass sie
meine Position in jeder Punkt
unterstützt inhaltlich und hat auch noch
weitere Belege eingereichten insofern
ist das von mir kein Alleingang das wird
von einigen so berichtet ich weiß
eigentlich nicht so richtig warum weil
das stimmt tut es nicht was für
Konsequenzen hat das jetzt diese dieser
Einspruch aus Karlsruhe was ziehen die
Fraktion vor allem die ampelfraktion
jetzt daraus für Konsequenzen das ist
diese verkürzten Verfahrensdauern gibt
es ja jetzt keine Erfindung beim
heizungsgesetz die gab es auch glaube
ich zu Kroko Zeiten schon aber
was werden Sie daraus jetzt lernen damit
sie noch nicht noch mal von von
Karlsruhe da gemaßt werden sind das dann
neue Verfahrensregeln neue Fristen dass
man ganz klar sagt wann es Ausnahmen
gibt also im Notfall ist klar muss ich
schnell gehen Ukraine kriegt und so
weiter wird es denn da jetzt auch von
Seiten der der Ampel Fraktionen eine
Veränderung geben dass das nicht noch
mal passiert
das Thema Verfahren beschäftigt uns
schon lange ich habe hier den
Änderungsantrag zum EEG 2020 dabei
übrigens 300 Seiten ist am 15.12.20
Energien Gesetz das am 15.12.20 von der
großen Koalition eine Stunde vor einer
sonderausschussitzung zugestellt worden
also deswegen ich glaube wir sehen dass
die Diskussion um Verfahren nicht ganz
neu ist da waren wir jetzt stehen
mit dem Änderungsantrag drei Tage vor
der Anhörung dran und haben ihn sogar an
alle Abgeordneten verschickt ein Novum
wirst sich nicht dass in den letzten
Legislatur gegeben hat ich weiß das weil
ich habe das verschickt entsprechend
ich möchte nur darauf hinweisen dass wir
alle Punkte haben vor unserer Tür wo wir
kehren müssen ja das ist ja ganz klar
und da wird mir Heimat auch zustimmen
was schließt man jetzt daraus ich wurde
vorschlagen dass wir jetzt nicht wieder
mit heißen Kopf neue Verfahren
geschäftsordnungsartikel und so weiter
reinwerfen eine Debatte die Beruhigung
braucht für alle sondern ja ich bin
offen für die Diskussion aber jetzt von
Knall auf Fall zu sagen wie Sie 14 Tage
bevor das Gesetz im Ausschuss ist muss
ein Antrag vorliegen
also das ist mit den jetzigen kommen
etwas unrealistisch
ja für die normale Gesetzgebung
Anführungszeichen
da müssen wir uns in Ruhe mal was
überlegen und am Ende des Tages ist die
Frage ob eben parlamentarische
Demokratie
wie sie in Deutschland funktionieren ob
man die in seines starres Korsett
pressen kann aber definitiv das hatte
ich ja gesagt ist das für uns natürlich
Anlass noch mal auch aus Schaden klug
werden denn es geht ja hier auch
tatsächlich um ein wichtiges Gesetz das
stellt ja von der AFD abgesehen
eigentlich niemand in Zweifel ja also
ich meine man muss ja tatsächlich noch
gucken wie Karlsruhe dann am Ende
tatsächlich entscheidet das wurde ja nur
dem einen Antrag stattgegeben ich bin
keine Juristin ich kann das nicht
beurteilen aber wahrscheinlich wäre es
schon klug als Regierung immer zu gucken
dass die Opposition auch Zeit hat und
natürlich die Experten eingesetzt auch
zu lesen und dann zu bewerten aber ich
glaube das in diesem Fall man wird es
sehen wird es wahrscheinlich keine
großen substanziellen Änderungen mehr
geben denn natürlich wird ja dieses
gesamte Gesetz und das gesamte Thema
wird ja schon seit Monaten diskutiert
ist ja nicht so als wäre das Thema an
sich vor zwei Tagen im Bundestag
gelandet
ist eine Meinung und es ist schon alles
ausgelotet was ist da an Kompromissen
geben könnte und was inhaltlich sinnvoll
ist und was nicht und das wird sich
jetzt auch nicht über den Sommer ändern
sondern
sie sehen ein Gesetz nur in den ganz
großen politischen Linien ein Gesetz des
180 Seiten hat hat auch sehr viele
Einzelregelungen die sehr oft misslingen
handwerklich der geht gar nicht ohne
politische Entscheidung Wärmepumpe ja
oder nein das Thema sondern das Thema
ist um ein ganz konkreten Fall in dem
jetzigen Gesetz zu nehmen es gibt
plötzlich eine ganz neue Definition was
ein Quartier ist anders als in anderen
Gesetzen wenn es darum Mieter Strom und
so weiter geht warum eigentlich dass er
nicht rechts und nicht links und nicht
grün und ich CDU und für diese Dinge
nehmen wir uns keine Zeit ich würde mich
aber als Abgeordneter verpflichtet dass
wir das ordentlich machen und für die
Rechtswahl ist ein eines der Gründe
warum die Verfahren so lange dauern
liegt daran dass diese Gesetze diese
technischen Defizite haben und dafür
brauchen wir mehr Zeit ich stimme dieser
badung zu das sollten jetzt aber Pause
jetzt nicht in einer Woche irgendwie so
ein Schnellschuss machen darüber redet
ja auch gar keiner aber völlig klar ist
dass wenn Sie hier nicht nur diese
Entscheidung sondern auch die früheren
Entscheidungen des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts zur Kenntnis
nehmen dann können wir nicht so
weitermachen wie wir das selber beim EEG
gemacht haben das habe ich damals
öffentlich kritisiert also damit meine
eigene Partei ich habe es kritisiert ich
fand es nicht in Ordnung und ich finde
es jetzt nicht in Ordnung und Verwaltung
wird es wissen wenn ich das im Ausschuss
mehrfach gesagt habe oder Plenum
mehrfach gesagt habe ich habe über
Monate im Bundestag gesagt Leute wir
können diese Verfahren so nicht
weitermachen
zurückziehen wenn es da jetzt eine neue
Einigung auf ein geregeltes Verfahren
gibt wenn es einen neues verfahrensystem
gäbe dann gibt es für diese Klage keinen
Anlass mehr und ich kann das auch nur
empfehlen weil wie der Bundestag seine
Regeln definiert das sollten eigentlich
Abgeordnete entscheiden und nicht
Karlsruhe Karlsruhe ist ja immer nur der
Notlage wenn man sich nicht einigt oder
es gibt ja noch nicht mal einen Prozess
ich hoffe sehr dass wir ein Prozess
beginnen zu sagen wir überlegen mal was
ist das normale Verfahren mit normalen
inkrafttretendes Dingen und dann muss
man sich auch in allverfahren zulassen
für Corona oder für kriegsfragen das ist
das völlig unbestritten auch in
Karlsruhe völlig unbestritten aber den
Fall haben wir hier nicht Herr Landsberg
auch die kommunenklagen jetzt nicht in
Karlsruhe sondern auch über zum Beispiel
die Bundespolitik ihr Kollege vom
deutschen Landkreis da kannst du in der
Hennicke hat das gesagt oft werden wir
gar nicht gehört unsere Belange werden
zu wenig berücksichtigt von der
Bundespolitik da geht es natürlich oft
und Finanzierungsfragen
ja wie sehen sie dieses Verhalten also
die Bundestagsfraktionen sind in einer
anderen Position zu Regierung aber
können sie solche Erfahrungen bestätigen
wird dazu wenig auf Ihre Belange
Rücksicht genommen also man hört uns man
aber man erhört uns nicht und bei dem
Beispiel zu bleiben relativ spät hat die
andere gesagt ja maßgeblich ist
eigentlich die kommunale wärmeplanung
das hat mir übrigens schon am Anfang
gesagt und wenn das so ist und das
bestreite ich auch gar nicht dann wäre
es natürlich sinnvoll zu sagen also wir
machen erstmal das kommunale
wärmeplanungsgesetz und dann das Gebäude
Energiegesetz oder wir beraten das
zusammen beides wäre auch jetzt noch
sinnvoll und möglich und ich wage mal
eine Prognose jetzt das wird laufen die
werden Anfang September das Gesetz so
durchwinken wie es jetzt auch in den
Ausschüssen beraten worden ist da wird
sich nichts Wesentliches ändern und dann
kommt das kommunale wärmeplanungsgesetz
und dann haben wir das nächste Reparatur
gesetzt für das Gebäude Energiegesetz
Rettig drauf weil sie nicht wissen wie
das wärmeplanungsgesetz tatsächlich
ausgeht und der Schlüssel liegt bei den
Kommunen und ich kann immer eine
appellieren auch an Politiker sie
gewinnen und verlieren waren nicht in
Berlin sondern immer vor Ort und ich
kann auch berichten im Zusammenhang mit
diesen Gesetzgebungsverfahren die Leute
vor Ort sind sowas von gefrustet sie
verstehen es nicht die Kommunikation der
Regierung insgesamt war ich bin ja
höflich mäßig wenn ich sage sehr mäßig
es sind natürlich auch Dinge gestreut
worden die auch nicht stimmt der
heizungshammer und wir können das alles
nicht bezahlen ist alles nicht richtig
aber die Leute hoch besorgt die Kommunen
hoch besorgt und das hat dann auch etwas
mit den Umfragen zu tun die wir erleben
und ich glaube wichtiger als die Frage
ob das jetzt noch 14 Tage dauert oder im
September ist sich zu überlegen wie
kommunizieren wir in diesem Land Politik
das ist doch wirklich das Argument dafür
dass die Bürger jetzt Planungssicherheit
brauchen und dass dieses Gesetz nicht
noch mal dem Wesen nach aufgenommen das
ist doch gar nicht verstanden
und deswegen haben die ampelfraktion ja
auch heute erklärt dass man das im
September so verabschieden wird und so
wie es auch im Ausschuss verabschiedet
worden ist eben um nicht noch mehr
Unruhe reinzubringen und Sie haben ja
Recht es war auch das Verfahren war
nicht viel gegeben hat kein
Schönheitspreis gewonnen keine Frage das
ist leider auch massiv unwohl gefühlt
worden durch falsch Behauptungen einen
angeblich nicht mit Holz heizen man muss
sofort seine Heizung rausreißen und so
weiter die kann nicht von der Ampel die
kam von anderer Seite und deswegen sind
dem Stand wo wir jetzt sind und ich
glaube jetzt ist der Punkt die neuen
Leitlinien des Gesetzes wie es jetzt da
steht sind in den Medien berichtet
worden damit das jetzt noch mal ändern
also das bringt genau die Unsicherheit
die sich hier beklagen deswegen wer mein
Vorschlag dass wir das jetzt einfach
konstruktiv zu Ende bringen gerne auch
überparteilich ich weiß dass sie auch
jemand sind der für Klimaschutz für die
wärmewende steht ich glaube es ist
niemandem gedient wenn die wärmewende in
diesem Land weiter schlecht
ne der nutzt jetzt dieses Thema heute
schon wieder um sein sehr fragwürdigen
Auftritt auf einer Demo in Bayern wo er
angekündigt hat er wollte sich die
Demokratie zurückholen ähm den schön zu
reden und das ist der Punkt wo ich sage
nein wir reden hier über eine
Verfahrensfrage und wir reden hier nicht
im Grundsatz wieder über die wärmewende
Demokratie und so weiter da kommen
wirklich ein Teufel die Frage natürlich
welche Munition die Ampel geliefert hat
dass ihre politischen Gegner davon damit
auf sie ballern können aber ganz kurz es
ging ja bei der Frage von Herrn oder bei
der Antwort von Herrn Landsberg darum
dass die wärmeplanung die kommunale
Voraussetzung ist für das heizungsgesetz
wird aber genau umgekehrt jetzt im
Parlament behandelt dazu würde ich gerne
was ist eine zeitliche Kopplung gegeben
und wenn wir Ihren Wunsch damit
entsprochen haben das besser zu verzahn
ist es ja gut also wir Grüne haben von
Anfang an gesagt dass wir eine
verpflichtende kommunale wärmeplanung
wollen das wollten damals nicht alle
Koalitionspartner später wollten ist
alle und insofern können Sie doch an dem
Punkt sagen ähm das ist gut gelungen in
dem Sinne und manche Bundesländer haben
ja bereits in kommunale wärmeplanung die
Baden-Württemberg Bayern wo ich herkomme
leider noch nicht und ich denke es ist
eine gute Sache sondern diesen Flicken
Teppich auf Bundesebene den in was in
der einheitliche Regelung zu überführen
also wir fahren die kommunale
wärmeplanung schon länger
aber die Orientierung der Bürger gibt es
nur wenn alles drei da ist nämlich die
wärmeplanung also wenigstens das Gesetz
zweitens die Förderung denn da haben sie
zwar an den schließungsantrag der jetzt
nicht mehr zur Geltung kommt aber
gemacht wo sie so die Eckpunkte
darstellen aber da sind natürlich viele
Fragen offen ist auch in der Anhörung
rausgekommen und der Frage des
Energiegesetz nämlich was ist mit der
konkreten Heizung und eigentlich geht es
noch ein viertes Element nämlich was ist
mit dem Thema Dämmung und so das muss
man zusammen denken und sie haben das
leider eine falschen Stelle angefangen
ich verstehe warum es haben sie ja
letztlich eben gesagt sie waren sich bei
der wärmeplanung nicht einig also fangen
wir mit dem Gag an weil sie hätten
warten müssen bis sie mit der
wärmeplanung durch sind in ihren
Gesprächen und dann das Geld zu machen
das Ergebnis ist doch ein Desaster wir
hatten 2022 eine gute Entwicklung bei
der Wärmepumpe wir hatten Rekordzahlen
bei der Wärmepumpe und 23 durch die
Umstellung die sie vorgenommen haben
insbesondere Förderbereich haben wir
jetzt einen deutlichen Rückgang der
Wärmepumpe dafür Rekordzahlen bei Gas
und Ölheizung das kann man doch nicht
ernsthaft ein gutes Ergebnis
sie haben schlechtere CO2 Werte weil sie
mehr Heizung mit Öl und Gas eingebaut
haben und haben einbauen lassen da kann
man doch nicht sagen das war gut und da
kann man sich auch nicht hinstellen und
sagen das war alles die Gas Lobby und so
weiter dann müssen Sie doch einmal auch
sagen dass unser Verfahren war
ungeeignet basierend auf ihre
Uneinigkeit das verstehe ich natürlich
schon das sie haben nicht bewusst ein
ungeeignetes Verfahren gewählt das
glaube ich ihm schon aber im Ergebnis
war das Verfahren völlig ungeeignet und
hat im Klimaschutz nicht gedient und hat
der wärmewende nicht gegeben
und das müssen Sie schon konzentrieren
und dann haben Sie auch noch ein
Verfahren genommen das Karlsruhe mit
meiner Erkältung voll sein so geht es
eigentlich nicht das ist eben kein
normales Verfahren das den Normen der
Verfassung entspricht und es darf auch
kein normales Verfahren damit sie auch
nicht nur im Zwiegespräch zwischen ihnen
beiden bleibt ich nehme gerne einen
Stichwort auf dem ich die
Förderregelungen die sind ja auch noch
nicht klar es ist zwar drin steht 30 %
für alle 30 % für die die weniger als
40.000 € im Monat brutto haben und die
ganz schnell sind kriegen noch einen
Bonus aber die Frage ist ja hat
Christian Lindner überhaupt genügend
Kohle in der Kasse um diese staatlichen
Förderungen überhaupt zu finanzieren und
will er die überhaupt in dieser Höhe
finanzieren das ist ja noch nicht klar
das heißt man gibt ein Gesetz auf den
Weg verabschiedet das und wir wissen
noch gar nicht was es ihm Wirklichkeit
dann die Leute kostet in dem Fall wie
viel Förderung sie dafür bekommen also
diese ganze Förderung der Wärmepumpen
ist im Klima und
transformationsfonds untergebracht das
ist ein Schattenhaushalt der zu großen
Teilen aber nicht komplett durch die
co2-abgaben gefüllt ist jetzt ist
natürlich noch unklar das ist glaube ich
ein Thema das wir hier nicht vertiefen
sollten wie hoch dann die CO2-Abgabe ab
2024 überhaupt ist ist natürlich auch
unklar im Moment ja genau muss man nicht
vertiefen ich würde mal tippen dass dann
am Ende über diesen Schattenhaushalt
eben doch noch weitere Schulen
aufgenommen werden weil da ja auch noch
die Bahn mit 15 Milliarden die Intel
Subventionen in Magdeburg mit 10
Milliarden und so weiter drin sind also
das überlegt jetzt keine ob das Geld
reicht und wie stark aber das will ich
gar nicht kritisieren also ich würde
jetzt mal denken dass die Förderung
kommt weil er sonst wäre wirklich Land
unter in der Ampel was ich an der
Förderung schwierig finde muss ich mal
deutlich sagen ist natürlich das da
wieder Prinzip Gießkanne gilt also es
kriegt jeder seine Förderung auch Leute
die also ich sag das jetzt etwas
überspitzt aber gibt es ja
willenbesitzer die sich mühelos die
Wärmepumpe auch ohne staatliche
Förderung nicht leisten könnten aber das
ist halt der politische Preis weil sonst
die FDP nicht mitmachen würde man kann
aber sagen dass jetzt die Leute die
wenig verdienen oder wenig haben und im
Angst haben sie könnten sich die
Wärmepumpe nicht leisten die werden
jetzt so unterstützt dass da wirklich
kein Problem entsteht
das Hauptproblem ihr dann noch einen
Satz das Hauptproblem war aber ich
tatsächlich dass sehr lange nicht klar
war wie die Förderung aussieht also es
war von der Wärmepumpe schon mal die
Rede aber die genaue Förderung kam
irgendwie nicht in Gang das lag auch
ganz wesentlich an der FDP da kann man
den Grünen eigentlich keinen Vorwurf
machen aber was aus meiner Sicht bei den
Grünen falsch gelaufen ist ist das weil
man sich in der Koalition nicht geeinigt
hat kam auch sonst nichts und das wäre
eigentlich der klassische Fall gewesen
wo man wo Partei und Fraktion sich
trennen müssen also wo habe ich hätte
sagen müssen ja ich bin in der Koalition
wir versuchen einen sozialen Ausgleich
wir haben uns noch nicht geeinigt und
die Grüne Partei hätte sagen müssen was
ihr vorschlagen ist und da kam aber
nichts so das heißt dadurch dass dieser
soziale Ausgleich nicht sofort am Anfang
immer mit kommuniziert wurde ist
überhaupt dieses Debakel entstanden wenn
man von Anfang an gesagt hätte Arme
Haushalte werden unterstützt und unser
Konzept sieht so aus wäre das ganze
Problem bei der FDP gelandet und die
hätten dann gucken können wie Sie aus
dieser Misere wieder rauskommen und das
ist ein Punkt den ich eigentlich gar
nicht verstehe und
ich hatte ja das Privileg habe gleich zu
fragen als das im Koalitionsausschuss
die Einigung gab und da gab es keinen
keine keine Antwort von ihm zum Thema
soziale Ausgleich und das war glaube ich
schon im März und das ist eine war
natürlich ein Verteiler Fehler das war
ja allerdings auch relativ
häufig kommt das ja dass man
letztendlich einfach nur die Kosten
sieht aber die Förderung die kosten ja
dämpfen soll für die Menschen gar nicht
so mitdenkt auch in der Bevölkerung ist
nicht so richtig angekommen ist also
doch ein Kommunikationsproblem für
erstmal bin ich froh wir haben ja als äh
grüne Fraktion gefordert
einkommensschwächere Haus 1980%
Förderung zu unterstützen jetzt sind wir
bei 70 Prozent Förderung gelandet also
da zeigt man wie
parlamentalen parlamentare sich gut in
den Prozess einbringen man kann jetzt im
Nachhinein viel sagen ich weiß nicht ob
uns diese xigiese hilft ich habe ja
schon gesagt es gibt kein
Schönheitspreis für das Verfahren
es gab aus meiner Sicht eigentlich genug
Zeit zu diskutieren weil ab dem 19 April
war das Gesetz ja schon Kabinett
verabschiedet und wir Grünen hätten sehr
früh in die parlamentarischen Beratung
einsteigen können ich hatte sie
angesprochen es ist medial einfach auch
sehr viel Verunsicherung geführt worden
und so kam eines zum anderen wir haben
keinen schönen Prozess ich glaube
niemand hat jetzt noch großes Interesse
über das Verfahren zu sprechen wenn ich
jetzt an dem Stammtisch Frage oder auf
dem Biergarten bierkellerfrage sondern
die Leute wollen wissen
1.1.2024 es geht los wie schaffen wir
die wärmewende und ich finde es gut wenn
wir darüber sprechen weil
es ist ja nun unstrittig Herr Heimann
dass in den vergangenen Jahren noch
Gasheizung finanziell gefördert wurden
das ist sehr veraltete Standards bei
Neubauten gefördert wird mit Milliarden
und da können Sie jetzt auch mal bitte
Zusagen ist es sehr gut dass wir das
geändert haben und dass wir jetzt
gemeinsam in Richtung gehen wir
irgendeine Chance haben diese 40 Prozent
CO2-Ausstoß im Gebäudesektor in den
Griff zu kriegen die Schritte liegen
jetzt vor uns ich bin also auch es ist
natürlich immer so dass auch unsere
Partei unsere Parteien nicht alles
richtig gemacht haben
das verstehen die Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer
aber ganz so einfach ist es jetzt nicht
also die Ampel hat das Kind mit dem Bade
ausgeschüttet und hat alle Förderungen
in dem Bereich gestrichen und so sehr
ich glaube ich hätte auch einen früheres
vereinbarverbot bei Neubauten ist ist
die Wärmepumpe natürlich richtig die
Wärmepumpe weil man ist nicht für alle
Gebäude geeignet für viele ja aber nicht
für alle und das für die und die die für
diesen ungeeignet ist die waren
natürlich diejenigen besorgt waren und
für die gab es keine richtige Antwort am
Anfang aber zur Förderung noch mal das
Ergebnis der Politik der großen
Koalition war ein Wärmepumpen
das muss man ja also sie müssen ja nach
dem Ergebnis gucken und nicht nur was in
welchen Paragraphen steht also ich bin
ja Unternehmer von meiner Ausbildung her
und ich Politiker und wir gucken halt
was hinten rauskommt und hinten
rauskommt was da rausgekommen 22 war gut
und nicht schlecht hat sicher der
ukrainekrieg auch noch mal geholfen muss
man auch fairerweise sagen aber
nein aber es waren die Regeln der großen
Koalition die da gewirkt haben ja
natürlich
22 angefangen zu regieren ich meine die
haben nicht am ersten angefangen und
dann war natürlich Abhängigkeit auch
ziemlich offenbar aber die Frage ist was
war die Jahre vorher ich würde jetzt
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so gerne so
weit in die Vergangenheit zurückgehen
ich mache das nur einmal weil sie ist
angekommen
Hersteller die eher manuell gefertigt
haben mich übertreib jetzt mal weil in
Deutschland ist nicht den großen Markt
gab also sozusagen
gibt ich finde es gut dass es die
Förderung gibt ich bin auch ziemlich
sicher dieses Geld wird da sein aber was
mich etwas wundert wer hat die meisten
Gebäude in Deutschland die Kommunen wir
haben 185 000 Gebäude davon sind 165.000
mit Öl und Gas beheizt dazu finde ich
nicht zu ihrem Gesetz was ist mit den
Liegenschaften des Bundes und der Länder
hätten wir nicht eigentlich eine
Vorbildfunktion nach dem Motto wir
machen das jetzt schon mal in den zwei
Jahren da müssen wir keinen
Kommunalpolitiker überzeugen und dann
sehen die Menschen ja das funktioniert
ja in der Schule in der Sporthalle da
steht nichts drin und es gibt viele
Kommunen die haben schlicht nicht das
Geld also das würde ich gerne noch mal
transportieren und ich wundere mich dass
diese ich ich sehe das man kann sagen
können Sie mir eine Kaserne in Bayern
sagen wo eine Solaranlage ist oder eine
Wärmepumpe in Zweifel gibt's das nicht
und bei der Masse der Kommunen nicht bei
allen ist das genauso und ich finde es
super wenn wir diesen Schwung gehen
sicher wollen indem wir auch wollen
jedenfalls auf die öffentliche Hand
schon mal übertragen denn das erleben
wir vor Ort dass die Leute sagen fangt
ihr doch erstmal an aber
eine wunderbare Möglichkeit auch für die
Kommunen eine wärmeplanung zu starten
sie haben schon gesagt einige haben das
schon gemacht in einigen Bundesländern
läuft das schon
über die Zeit drängt ja auch im Juli
2026 muss das in den größeren Städten
sein im Juli 2018 seine kleineren
Städten und wenn es diese wärmeplanung
bis dahin nicht gibt dann gilt für alle
Haushalte in Deutschland dieses Gesetz
das heißt dann können sie gar nicht
auswählen zwischen Fernwärme
wasserstoffnetz und Wärmepumpe sondern
sie müssen sich dann für etwas
entscheiden was vor Ort da ist kriegen
denn die Kommunen das hin in diesen zwei
in diesen drei bzw fünf Jahren also das
ist ziemlich sportlich hängt natürlich
an der Ausformulierung des
wärmeplanungsgesetzes sie haben richtig
gesagt in Baden-Württemberg gibt's das
schon Frage wird die dort bestehende
wärmeplanung anerkannt was sind die
Voraussetzungen wie viel Daten muss ich
von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern erheben ich
warne davor also deine Schafe
Betrachtung mit Personen und allem zu
machen an sich sind die Daten da aber
die Masse der Kommunen macht das nicht
selber sie macht das mit Unternehmen bei
einer kleinen Kommune nicht unter
100.000 Euro und die haben natürlich
eine Flasche Sekt aufgemacht nachdem sie
wissen wir werden noch mehr gebraucht
wir werden uns bemühen das zu schaffen
ich bin da auch zuversichtlich aber ganz
sicher ist das nicht wir haben überall
den Fachkräftemangel und eigentlich
spannend wird es erst danach ich habe
mich jetzt entschieden nehmen wir mal an
als Kommune ein Fernwärmenetze baut das
ist eine gigantische auf die müssen
ganze Stadt umkrempeln was ich ja nicht
für falsch halten nur es wird
wahrscheinlich nicht so schön gehen wie
der Gesetzgeber sich das fairerweise
immer vorstellt wir sind bemüht aber das
ist ja einer der Gründe die wir auch im
Gesetzgebungsverfahren gesagt haben wir
brauchen flexiblere Regelungen weil
niemand von hier uns am Tisch weiß wie
viel Grün Wasserstoff gibt es in 10 oder
15 Jahren wir sind auf dem richtigen Weg
aber ob wir den Weg wirklich erreichen
weiß ich nicht es wird viel erzählt aber
entscheiden sich was erzählt wird und
was wir erreichen und das müssen wir den
Menschen vermitteln um das tun wir aus
meiner Sicht nach wie vor zu wenig
unabhängig jetzt von dem Verfahren vom
Verfassungsgericht und wozu wird das
Verfahren führen die Diskussion wird
jetzt weitergehen über den Sommer und
wir sind ja hier ehrlich miteinander
warum denn diese Hetze die Hetz war doch
nur wegen der Wahl in Hessen und in
Bayern wenn die beiden Wahlen nicht
wären hätte man gesagt na ja jetzt
machen wir es mal Sommerpause und nach
der Sommerpause machen das zusammen ich
kann das politisch verstehen aber
sachlich darf ich da meinen kleinen
Einschub machen ist was so ein Schritt
zurück in der Diskussion hier bei uns
sie haben ja heute die zwei
Fraktionsvorsitzender haben das ja auch
verkündet es wird jetzt genauso wie es
beschlossen worden ist in den Bundestag
eingehen in der ersten Septemberwoche
also diese sogenannte
Beschlussempfehlung des Ausschusses wird
zur Wahl gestellt und das wird dann auch
eins zu eins so wie es jetzt
wortwörtlich im Gesetzentwurf steht
verabschieden
oder könnte es sein dass ich zum
Beispiel ihre
koalitionsfreundinnen und Freunde von
der FDP bis Anfang September noch
irgendwas anderes einfallen lassen und
vielleicht für das ein oder andere
Bändchen am Paket wieder hochziehen
also die Fraktionsvorsitzenden haben das
gemeinsam kommuniziert das Wort gilt
darauf verlasse ich mich auch und die
Hetze kann ich wirklich nicht erkennen
also wir diskutieren seit März über
dieses Gesetz und ich glaube tatsächlich
mehr hat heute ein Journalist gesagt
dass er sehr gerne morgen in Urlaub
gefahren wäre ist nicht mein
Abgeordneter mit dem Gag abgeschlossen
also ich glaube einfach sowohl
Abgeordnete Bürgerinnen und Bürger
Journalisten und Journalisten
Moderatorin Moderatorin würden gerne
auch noch andere Themen in Deutschland
diskutieren oder dann z.B die
Einzelheiten in den wärmeplanungsgesetz
diskutieren oder das Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz wir brauchen die
Menschen auch für den Einbau der
Wärmepumpen und so weiter also wir
müssen einfach Vorankommen sonst werden
wir diese ganzen Aufgaben die in der
Legislatur auf uns zu kommen auch nicht
schaffen und wenn Sie erlauben möchte
ich gerne noch zwei Beispiele sagen was
ich aus meiner Sicht für die Kommunen
auch verbessert hat weil sie haben jetzt
hier auf die Herausforderung abgestellt
was ich richtig finde aber ich habe bei
mir vor Ort mehrfach beobachten im
letzten Jahren wie Kommunen versucht
haben wie sauer Bier Fernwärmeanschlüsse
zu verkaufen da war dann die Wahl
Beispiel in der Stadt Coburg
Müllheizkraftwerk ist jetzt auch nicht
aller Tage Abend aber aktuell kriegt man
dann noch Wärme draus will man sich die
Gasheizung einbauen lassen oder Wärme
aus dem Müllheizkraftwerk es hat niemand
die Abwärme genommen alle haben eine
Gasheizung eingebaut oder wir haben in
Bayern 40% könnten wir nominell aus
Geothermie bestreiten Wärme es hat
niemanden interessiert weil es war ja
nicht wirtschaftlich Geothermie zu
machen und das sind ja alles Punkte für
die Kommunen die jetzt diese Chance
haben diese Netze aufgenommen
wir brauchen das ist aber eine Frage der
Landes Anschluss wird Benutzung waren
also das kann nicht sein dass wir jetzt
wärmeplanung machen und dann haben sie
inzwischen alle die Wärmepumpe und
wenige Leute müssen an Demenz viel
bezahlen das kann ich die richtige Weg
sein aber auch da höre ich aus der Ampel
von ihrer baumministerin ja anschließend
benutzen Zwangs problematisch also ein
bisschen Zwang ist not wirklich wenn wir
vorankommen
ich glaube ach so ja genau die die
Freiheit des Marktes feiert und das ist
aber total Kontrakt produktiv und das
ist das eine Problem dass sie völlig
richtig beschreiben dass die Kommunen ja
Planungssicherheit haben müssen welche
Haushalte dann auch zur Verfügung stehen
und das andere ist glaube ich auf der
Konsumentenseite oder auf der Seite der
Hauseigentümer dass die jetzt alle total
verwirrt sind was jetzt mit der
Gasheizung ist und man kann jetzt nur
allen abraten davon sich eine Gasheizung
in irgendeiner Form da hinzustellen weil
es diesen Wasserstoff nicht geben wird
also das ist der grüne Wasserstoff wird
gebraucht in der Industrie und der wird
auch nicht billig sein also man kann
wirklich nur jedem empfehlen jetzt
endlich mal die Wärmepumpe einzubauen es
sei denn er kann sich irgendwie eine
kommunales Angebot mit Fernwärme hängen
aber auf keinen Fall eine individuelle
Gasheizung wirklich bitte nicht
also da sind ja einer Meinung aber gut
erstmal so deutlich sagen das fehlt noch
dass die CDU sagt hier bitte alle
Wärmepumpe richtig geil über meine
Positionen und dann wird es auch mehr in
den Medien stehen aber noch mal zurück
das Interview ist gebucht
aber die Verwaltung sie machen ein
bisschen den nächsten Fehler wenn Sie
das Verfassungsgerichtsurteil sehen dann
müssen sie der Opposition die Chance
geben erneut ein großanträge zu stellen
wenn Sie den Beschlussempfehlung nicht
wieder aufmachen im Ausschuss
dann laufen sie in die nächste
Verfassungswidrigkeit ein und Sie werden
sich erinnern dass ich das im Ausschuss
mehrfach gesagt habe das ist nicht
verfassungsgemäß ist was hier passiert
sie haben nicht zugehört auch Sie
persönlich mich und ich sag's Ihnen
jetzt auch öffentlich wieder wenn sie so
machen werden sie im September die
nächste Pleite erleben und ein formell
verfassungsvideos gesetzt verabschieden
dass ich nicht will dass es für
verfassungswidrig ist weil es niemanden
hilft aber die Verfassung die ich gerade
kommt von ihnen nicht von mir
Verfassungsgericht hat ja selber die die
Möglichkeit in der Sondersitzung noch
eingeräumt sogar
Moment es geht um die Ausschusssitzung
die wieder aufgemacht werden muss
ausdrücklich auch in der im Beschluss
noch mal so festgehalten
aber Sie müssen die Ausschusssitzung
wieder öffnen dass die Opposition
Anträge stellen kann und sagen Sie mir
hinterher nicht das haben sie nicht
gewusst wenn Sie die nächste Pleite von
Karlsruhe erhalten
ist auch noch gar nicht abgeschlossen
Auseinandersetzung ja oder nein das ist
ja auch was wir fordern wir sagen wir
würden gerne das ein oder andere was wir
mal eben hingeschrieben haben auch
vertiefen und wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe die Diskussion wird es
diese Möglichkeit gar nicht geben
das nach wie vor die Art und Weise wie
dieses Gesetz auf Weg gebracht worden
ist der Fehler war hat da der
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck zu
unglücklich agiert hat er erst seine
Beamten vor allem einen Patrick Graichen
machen lassen und dann musste er immer
hektischer hinterher reagieren gar nicht
mal so sehr regieren sondern reagieren
muss es ständig zurücknehmen war ständig
in der Öffentlichkeit mal gut gelaunt
mal schlecht gelaunt ist das diese
Forderung zu sagen wir müssen das
irgendwie in irgendeiner Weise noch mal
neu denken noch mal neu aufsetzen ich
auch berechtigt sie haben ja vorhin
selber gesagt es gibt keinen Aspekt der
nicht schon in den letzten Monaten
diskutiert worden wäre und zwar Exegese
habe ich ja auch schon Stellung genommen
sehr ausführlich betreiben es stimmt
einfach nicht dass wir zum Beispiel über
die Belange der Kommunen hat es an
keiner Stelle eine Diskussion gegeben
das ist nicht die Diskussion Wärmepumpe
Gasofen halt Kurs nicht Offenheit die
ist rauf und runter diskutiert worden
aber dieser politisch vielleicht noch
interessanter aber die Frage wie wir die
Kommunen einbinden wie das denn mit
nahverbensystemen geht wie geht das da
die Förderung so wie das jetzt wird das
für die Kommunen viel zu teuer für die
Fernwärme ihr fernwärmegipfel vor vier
Wochen der nichts mit dem Geld zu tun
hat hat gesagt wir wollen 600.000
Fernwärme Anschlüsse pro Jahr haben ich
wäre ja sehr dafür aber mit dem jetzigen
Instrument wird es auf gar keinen Fall
klappen es gibt eine ganze Reihe von
Fragen die das Geld unmittelbar
betreffen die sind nie diskutiert worden
und das Gebäude energiegesetzbuch
diskutiert worden und sie machen den
nächsten verfassungsrechtlichen Fehler
wenn sie es nicht tun ich habe bei der
Diskussion was das jetzt auch politisch
bedeutet auch für die Ampel das ist ja
der Untertitel auch der Sendung wird ich
besichtigen da auch selbst
in dieser Sendung oder den Sendungen der
Phönix Runde oft jemand übersehen der
eigentlich eine ganz zentrale Rolle
spielen sollte weil er von Amts wegen
eigentlich auch dafür zuständig ist
nämlich Scholz Olaf derzeit
Bundeskanzler der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland muss man noch mal erwähnen
der tut ja immer so weil man als hätte
er mit all diesen Dingen vor allem wenn
es Konflikte gibt wenig zu tun gestern
Abend wird kolportiert auf dem Hof ist
der SPD-Fraktion hätte er noch kurz vor
21:48 Uhr ganz sicher gesagt das Gesetz
kommt am Freitag der Einspruch wird
abgeschmettert das parlamentarische
Verfahren war toll das Gesetz ist toll
alles ist toll das hat dann nur noch
Minuten gehalten
also erstmal muss ich sagen Scholz ist
ja auch Jurist und ich kenne sehr viele
Juristen die sicher waren dass Karlsruhe
das abschmettern würden also das ist
jetzt nicht so dass die Mehrheit der
Juristen vorher gesagt hat Herr Heilmann
hatten Erfolg feiern sondern die Chancen
wurden anders gesehen also insofern ist
Scholz als Jurist da sozusagen der
typische Jurist gewesen ich glaube dass
man fairerweise lesen was ich
geschrieben habe vielleicht nicht
äußern aber die politisch aber auch die
rechtliche Einschätzung von vielen
Juristen war die Person
ehrlicherweise muss man ja sagen dass es
wirklich schwer hat das ist die erste
Ampel die wir jemals hatten in
Deutschland und diese zwei kleinen
Parteien Grüne und FDP dazu koordinieren
ist wirklich schwierig zumal ist ja so
ist und das muss man wirklich ganz
deutlich sagen die FDP ja als wäre das
ein Heim zu schwer erziehbar
die FDP ist also schon wirklich
schwierig weil die das sagt sie auch
selber ganz offen als Taktik hat
Oppositionsarbeit in der Regierung also
die FDP ist an konstruktive Arbeit gar
nicht interessiert sondern was die Macht
ist sie kämpft um Sichtbarkeit und wir
hatten ja schon die Bedeutung der beiden
Landtagswahlen Bayern und Hessen und das
ist für die FDP von überragender
Bedeutung weil es so ist in Hessen sind
in den Umfragen das ist jetzt die
neueste Umfrage bei 5,5 Prozent das
heißt Sie können nicht sicher sein dass
Sie einziehen und in Bayern sitzen sie
bei vier Prozent bei Grünkohl
Prozent und wenn man jetzt sich die
bundesumfragen anguckt das ist ja sehr
interessant sind die Grünen immer noch
bei 14,5% ungefähr das heißt sie haben
genauso viele Stimmen wie 2021 sie haben
überhaupt nichts verloren auch nichts
gewonnen aber auch nichts verloren
während die FDP sitzt bei
6%, also das ist ja schon in der
Todeszone nicht bei 5 % fliegt man raus
und sie hatten
20211,5 %. das heißt die ähm die FDP ist
in einer absolut strategisch gesehen die
soldatenlage und was ich interessant
finde ist das Lindner ganz
offensichtlich nicht lernfähig ist der
macht jetzt die ganze Zeit
Opposition in der Regierung und seine
Stimmen werden halbiert da würde ja
wahrscheinlich jeder andere denken okay
es wird Zeit sich wahrscheinlich mehr
aus konstruktiv zu sein und auch mein
Vorschlag zu machen aber das läuft nicht
das heißt
da hat es Scholz schwer mit der FDP und
dann ist noch ein weiterer Punkt den
davon auch nicht unterschätzen für
Scholz ist ganz klar dass er 2025 ist ja
noch weit hin aber da ist wieder eine
Wahl nur Kanzler bleiben kann wenn die
FDP im Bundestag bleibt das heißt
toleriert diese ganzen nicht so da würde
auch dafür bleibt der FDP nicht dazu
führen
der Kanzlerkandidat der CDU wurde ja
noch spannend nicht aber jedenfalls muss
die FDP drin bleiben so und deswegen hat
man dann da diesen Zirkus wo man als
Zuschauer denkt das kann ja nicht wahr
sein aber diese ganzen politischen
Medien nicht nur ums heizungsgesetz aber
dass sie sondern auch um andere
politische Fragen von großer Bedeutung
dass die Union nicht unbeteiligt helfen
ja eigentlich nur einer Partei der AFD
das ist leider so
und es gelingt uns im Moment nicht
ausreichenden Maße die Alternative
darzustellen die die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger überzeugen finden
und deswegen und das liegt daran dass
sie auch nicht konstruktiv sind sie
vielleicht aber nicht ernst also ich
weiß jetzt nicht ich würde jetzt diesen
taktischen Versuch versuchen abzuwehren
dass Sie uns immer in Grüppchen
aufteilen und so weiter
die ich glaube auch nicht dass unser
Problem übermäßiger Streit intern ist es
ist nicht so ganz einfach in so einem
oppositionsgebiet gegen eine
populistische Partei wenn man zwei wenn
Sie so wollen von rechts und links das
können sie ja in der ganzen Welt
beobachten immer dann wenn eine Center
ride heißt das international also eine
rechts der Mitte stehende Partei davon
daneben noch eine rechtspopulistische
Partei hat und eine regierende Partei
die dann links der Mitte ist dass das
für ganz egal welchen Lande schwierige
Konstellation ist
auch daran dass die Menschen kein
Vertrauen zur Regierung haben sie
verstehen
sie verstehen es nicht sie vertrauen
kommt mir nicht und sie haben sehen
keine Zukunft und dann ist natürlich
einfach für Leute die sagen alles Mist
alles misten ihr müsst nur dann kommen
die Ausländer raus und all diese
Geschichten das ist alles Quatsch wie
wir alle gemeinsam wissen und deswegen
sage ich ich glaube erfolgreich gegen
Extremismus kommen wir nur weiter mit
einer vernünftigen
Kommunikationsstrategie und da sind wir
wieder bei unserem Thema wir müssen das
anders kommunizieren was Sie gesagt
haben baut euch alle eine Wärmepumpe ein
das ist die Lösung habe nur so noch
nicht gehört jedenfalls nicht verbunden
trotzdem mit einem Ausblick jetzt ähm
auf die nächste Zeit es ging ja immer
und die Zukunft in dieser Sendung die
parlamentarischen Sommerferien könnten
für die Ampel das reinste Vergnügen
werden viele steinpunkte sind nicht
abgeräumt das im heizungssitz ist auch
noch keine Haken dran Migration
Kindergrundsicherung Haushalt was wird
aus der Ampel schaffen anders wir haben
uns inhaltlich geeinigt wir haben das
Glück noch sozialer gemacht wir haben
verknüpft wieder kommunalen wärmeplanung
und so wird mit dem Schuh draus so wird
es auch verabschiedet werden und
ansonsten hoffe ich dass der Sommer kein
totale Dürre Sommer wird und auch wenn
er kein dürü Sommer hier zu Sommer wird
müssen wir was gegen die Klimakrise tun
das sollten alle demokratischen Parteien
zusammenarbeiten und
Vorschläge sind die Klimaschutz machen
und nicht nur Gesetze schlecht reden für
den Klimaschutz weil sonst kommen wir
nicht mehr dann wird die Ampel in
Düsseldorf für Demokratie nein wir
werden
Aussage ich bedanke mich bei dieser
Beratung bei Ulrike Herrmann bei Thomas
Heilmann und bei Gerd Landsberg liebe
Zuschauer liebe Zuschauer das war die
letzte reguläre Phoenix Runde vor
unserer Sommerpause die letzte reguläre
weil wir nächste Woche noch eine
sonderphönix Runde haben zum NATO gibt
in Vilnius moderiert dann von Anke
blättner die erste reguläre Phönix Runde
nach der Sommerpause ist am 29 August
aber Phoenix geht nicht in den
Sommerschlaf wir haben für Sie ein
Sommerprogramm vorbereitet das ist in
sich hat
attraktive Dokument hat Nationen
Reportagen schauen Sie rein es lohnt
sich
aktuelles bei Phoenix der Tag mit Maya
Weber darin unter anderem eine andere
wichtige Entscheidung im Bundestag oder
besser gesagt nicht Entscheidungen
nämlich zwei gescheiterte Abstimmungen
über die Sterbehilfe bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]